[Music]
oh
peaceful peaceful peaceful peace
peaceful peaceful peace
[Music]
May the peace mercy and blessings of
Allah subhana tala
God Almighty be on all of
you we begin
this concluding session the evening
session of the 10day International
Islamic conference and exhibition going
on for the last 10
days with the
karat by
Brother Dr Oman Muhammad sidiki from
Saudi
Arabia
[Music]
sh
in
[Music]
to
w
[Music]
amim
May
[Music]
C
be
[Music]
in
now we have the translation of the Kat
being read out by Brother Musa s Antonio
from
[Music]
Australia recite
oh Muhammad what has been revealed to
you of the book and establish
prayer indeed prayer prohibits
immorality and
wrongdoing and the remembrance of Allah
is greater and Allah knows that which
you
do and do not argue with the people of
the book except in a way that is
best except for those who commit
Injustice amongst them
and say we believe in that which has
been revealed to us and revealed to you
and our God and your God is
one and we are Muslims in submission
unto him and thus we have sent down to
you the book and those to whom we
previously gave the scripture believe in
it and among these are those who believe
in it and none reject all verses except
the
disbelievers and you did not recite
before it any
Scripture nor did you inscribe one with
your right
hand then otherwise the falsifiers would
have had cause for
doubt rather it is distinct verses
preserved within the breasts of those
who have been given
knowledge and none reject our verses
except the
wrongdoers but they say why are not
signs sent down to him from his Lord say
the signs are only with Allah and I am
only a clear
Warner and is it not sufficient for them
that we reveal to you the book which is
recited to them indeed in that is a
mercy and a reminder for those who
believe I Dr Muhammad Nik am your
host for this evening's program on
behalf of the Islamic Research
Foundation and our thousands of
volunteers who have put this program
together for our brothers and sisters
present here
today and the vast multitudes the
millions of people people watching this
program live on television all over the
world on
satellites past 10 Arabs at B 4 Galaxy
A10 in USA and Canada South America and
eurobird one covering up the whole of
Europe as well as the sky TV channel 823
in
UK I welcome all of you to this
important event the concluding session
of our
10day International Islamic conference
and exhibition on the theme peace the
solution for
Humanity this is the theme
session and we have none other than Dr
Zakir
NY available before you to address this
full session
alhamdulillah a medical doctor by
professional
training Dr Zakir NY clarifies Islamic
viewpoints and clears misconceptions
about Islam using the Quran authentic
Hadith and other religious scriptures as
a basis in conjunction with reason logic
and scientific
facts he's 42 years
old Dr Zakir is popular for his critical
analysis and convincing answers to
challenging questions posed by audiences
after his public public talks as he
would address you in the question and
answer session and open one after his
talk
too in the last 12 years Dr Zakir Nik
has delivered more than 1200 public
lectures in many countries worldwide in
addition to numerous more public talks
in India he has successfully
participated in several symposia and
dialogues with prominent personalities
of other faiths his public dialogue with
Dr William Campbell in USA on the topic
the Quran and the Bible in the light of
science held in Chicago USA on April 1st
2000 was a resounding success in
establishing that the Quran matches with
established scientific facts his public
dialogue with the Renown personality of
India SRI Ravi Shankar on the topic the
concept of God in Hinduism and Islam in
the light of sacred scriptures held in
the city of Bangalore India on January
21st 2006 two was a grand success in
highlighting toed the Oneness and unity
of
God much before
this shik Ahmed dad the world famous
orator on Islam and comparative religion
who had earlier called Dr Zakir NY dad
Plus in
1994 in May 2000 presented a plague to
him which stated awarded to Dr Zakir
Abdul Karim n for his achievement in the
field of dawa and the study of
comparative religion son what you have
done in four years had taken me 40 years
to accomplish
alhamdulillah and shik didat happens to
be a Pioneer in speaking on comparative
religion in
English Dr Zakir Nik appears regularly
on programs and
interviews on many International TV and
radio channels in more than 200
countries of the world he has authored
many books on Islam and comparative
religion including the Quran and modern
science compatible or incompatible is
the Quran God's word woman in Islam
subjugated or protected concept of God
in major religions and answers to
non-muslims common questions about
Islam in the concluding theme session of
the peace the solution for Humanity the
10day
International Islamic conference and
exhibition to present his public
talk on this vital topic of the day is
Islam the solution for
Humanity let's welcome the dynamic
International orator on Islam and
comparative religion Dr zaker
[Applause]
n
f
[Applause]
alhamdulillah the respected Scholars and
speakers of from different parts of the
world my respected elders and my dear
brothers and sisters I welcome all of
you with the Islamic
greetings may peace
mercy and
blessings of Allah subhana wa ta'ala be
on all of
you the topic
of this last
session and the last lecture of this
10day International Islamic
conference is
is
Islam the solution for
Humanity
Islam is derived from the root toward
Salam or
Salam which means peace it's also
derived from the Arabic word FM which
means to submit your will to almighty
God in short Islam means peace acquired
by submitting a will to almighty God so
the topic of today's lecture
is is peace acquired by submitting a
will to almighty God the solution for
Humanity Islam unlike other religions
and other ways of life which only cater
either to to the physical needs of the
body or the spiritual
aspect most of the religions they mainly
cater to the spiritual aspects and the
needs of the soul and some isms like
materialism Etc as well as communism
they mainly cater to the physical needs
of the body Islam alhamdulillah it
caters to
both the spiritual need of the Soul as
well as the physical need of the body
body it has a dual
role and as
far as the solution to humanity is
concerned the Glorious Quran is the most
positive book in the world it is a
proclamation to humanity it
is a fountain of mercy and wisdom it is
a warning to the
heedless
it's a guide to the aing it's an
assurance to those in
doubt it's a Solace to the suffering and
it is a hope to those in
despair this glorious Quran has the
solution to the problems of
humanity now
whenever anyone gives you a solution you
would like to know the source you'd like
to know the authenticity for example if
you're sick and if someone gives you a
prescription you'd like to know that who
has written the prescription is it a
doctor what are his
qualifications similarly people would
like to
know that who is the author of this
glorious Quran people like to know what
is the authenticity of this gous
Quran but
natural I cannot give the solution for
Humanity I am zero in
Islam the best person to give the
solution for Humanity is the creator of
humanity it is the creator of humankind
it is the creator of the world it is the
creator of the
universe the best solution for the
problems of humanity can be given by the
sustainer by the cherisher of the
humankind of the whole world as well as
the whole
universe
so before we
dwell into the topic I would first like
to spend a few
minutes telling the audience the
authenticity of this book and the source
of this book I'll try and prove in
nutshell that the Glorious Quran is the
word of almighty God as well as those
people who do not believe in almighty
God I will try to prove to them the
existence of Allah subhana wa tala of
almighty
God when an atheist comes and approaches
me and when he tells me that I do not
believe in a God the first thing I do is
I congratulate
him people may wonder why is Zakir
congratulating an
atheist the reason I'm congratulating an
atheist is because he is
thinking most of the human beings they
do blind
Bel he's a Christian because father is a
Christian he's a Hindu because father is
is Hindu some Muslims they're Muslim
because their fathers are
Muslim this atheist he is thinking he
may be coming from religious background
but he does not agree that the god his
parents are
worshiping that they can be such a
God so he disagrees in the existence of
God and the reason I congratulate him is
because he has said the first part of
the Islamic shahada the first part of
the Islamic Creed that Isa that there is
no God the only thing I have to do now
is to prove to him illah but Allah which
I shall do
inshallah here half my job is
done to the other non-muslims first I
have to prove to them that the God
they're worshiping is not a true God
here half my job is done he has already
agreed that there's no God so only thing
I have to prove to him is the existence
of the true Almighty God that is
Allah which I shall do
inshallah most of the
atheist they think that science is
Ultimate nowadays this is the age of
Science and Technology and they feel
that science is
Ultimate
and if you ask any
atheist that
Suppose there is an equipment there is a
gadget which no no one in the world has
ever seen no one has heard of and if
that Gadget is brought in front of this
atheist and the question is asked that
who will be the first person who will be
able to tell you the mechanism of this
gadget the mechanism of this
equipment the will
reply that it will be the
Creator some may say the manufacturer
some may say the maker some may say the
inventor some may say the producer
whatever they say it will be somewhat
similar either it will be the Creator
the manufacturer the maker it will be
the inventor it will be somewhat similar
don't grapple with the words just keep
that answer at the back of your
mind ask him the question that how did
our universe come into
existence he will tell you that
initially there was a primary
nebula later on on there was a secondary
separation there a big
bang which gave rise to galaxies the
Stars the Sun the planets and the earth
on which we live this they call it as
the big
bang when we asked the atheist that when
did you come to know about this creation
of the universe Big Bang so he will tell
you we came to know recently 30 years
back 40 years
back I tell him that this information
about the creation of the universe is
mentioned in this book The Glorious
Quran 1,400 years ago in a nutshell it's
mentioned inia chapter number 21 verse
number
30 do not the unbelievers
see that the heavens and the Earth they
were joined together and we clo them
asunder this big bang what you're
talking about is already mentioned in
the Quran 1400 years ago who could have
mentioned this in the Quran he will tell
you maybe it's a flock don't argue with
him
continue what is the shape of this Earth
so he will tell you that previously the
human beings thought that the earth on
which we live is
flat it was in 1577 when s Francis Drake
he sailed around the earth that he
proved that the Earth was
spherical what you came to know in 1577
is already mentioned in the Quran 1400
years ago in Surah naat chapter number
79 verse number 30 where it's
mentioned and thereafter we have made
the Earth egg shaped the Arabic worda
one of its meaning is an expanse and the
Earth is an expanse the other meaning is
derived from the Arabic word duya which
means an egg and we know that the earth
on which we live is not completely round
like a ball it is flattened from the
pole and bulging from the center it is
geosphere in shape and the Arabic word
daha does not refer to a normal egg it
specifically refers to the Egg of an
ostrich and if we analyze the shape of
the Egg of an ostrich it too is GEOS
feric in shape who could have mentioned
14400 years ago that the shape of the
earth is
geospheres
The Atheist may say maybe your Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him he was an
intelligent person don't
argue
continue the light of the moon is it its
own light or is it a reflected light the
the will tell you previously we thought
that the light of the moon was its own
light recently in science 100 years back
200 years back 300 years back we came to
know that the light of the moon is not
its own light but it is the reflected
light
Quran mentions in Surah fan chapter
number 25 verse number 61 blessed is he
who has made the constellations in the
sky and placed therein Sun having its
own light and moon having a reflection
of light having borrowed
light the Arabic word used for sun is
Shams it's always described as s of
meaning a torch or a blazing lamp the
Arabic word used in the Quran for Moon
isar its light is always described as
Moon or meaning borrowed light or a
reflection of light nowh does the Quran
refer to the Moonlight as its own light
who could have mentioned this in the
Quran 1400 years
ago The Atheist maybe after a long pause
he will
say maybe your
prophet he was extra
intelligent don't argue
continue when I was in school I passed
my school in
1982 I had learned in the subject of
Science and geography that the sun
though it revolved it did not rotate
about its own
axis the will ask is this mention in the
Quran I will tell no no this is what I
learned in
school more than 25 years back this is
what I learned in
school but when I read the verse of the
Quran in Surah Amia chapter number 21
verse number 33
says it's Allah who has created the
night and the
day the Sun and the
Moon Bon each one traveling in orbit
with its own motion the Arabic word yes
bhun describes the motion of a moving
body indicating that the sun besides
revolving it is also rotating about its
own axis and today science tells us that
the sun takes approximately 25 days to
complete one
notation who could have mentioned this
in the Quran 1400 years ago which
science has discovered recently just a
couple of decades earlier when I was in
school I didn't know about this now all
the
textbooks they say very clearly that the
sun besides revolving even rotates about
his own Anis who could have mentioned
this in the
Quran and most probably the atheist
he'll be silent don't wait for the reply
continue today's science tells us that
that our universe is expanding which we
discovered recently a couple of hundred
years back Quran mentions in Surat
chapter number 51 verse number 47 that
we have created the expanding Universe
the vastness of space Arabic word mus it
means the expanding Universe the
vastness of
space they may be many critics of Islam
who will say it is nothing great that
the Quran speaks about astronomy since
the Arabs were advanced in the field of
astronomy and I do agree with them that
astronomy but I'd like to remind them it
was centuries after the Quran was
revealed that the Arabs became advanced
in the field of astronomy so it's from
the Quran that the Arabs learned about
astronomy and not the vice
versa in the field of hydrology when we
as the atheist that when did we come to
to know about his water
cycle so he will tell you that sir
Bernard palac in 1580 was the first
person who described the present water
cycle how does the water evaporate from
the ocean it forms into clouds moves
into the interior it falls on at rain
and the water cycle is rep
finished this water cycle is mentioned
in the Quran in great detail 14400 years
ago the Quran mentions too that the
water evaporates from the ocean forms
into clouds the clouds join then move
into the interior then the water falls
down and the water table is replenished
the Quran speaks about hydrology and the
water cycle in great detail in several
verses in Sur AUM 39 verse number 21 in
Sur Room chapter number 30 verse number
24 in Sur chapter number 23 verse number
18 in chapter number 15 verse number 22
in Sur n chapter number 24 verse number
43 in Sur Room chapter number 30 verse
number 48 in Sur chapter number 7 verse
57 in Sur chapter number 13 verse number
17 in Sur fan chapter number 25 verse
number 48 49 in Sur f chapter number 35
verse number 9 in Surah Yassin chapter
number 36 verse number 34 in Surah
jashia chapter number 45 verse number 5
in Surah chapter number 50 verse number
9 and 10 in Sur 56 verse number 68 to 70
in Sur mul 67 verse number 30 in Sur 86
verse number 11 you can
quote only keep on quoting the
references the Quran speaks about the
water cycle in great
detail who could have mentioned this in
the Quran 1400 years
ago don't wait for the answer to
continue the Quran it speaks about
geology that the mountains have got pegs
which give stability to the
Earth it's mentioned Sur chapter number
78 verse number 6 and
7 in the field of oceanology we knew
that were two types of water salt and
sweet but the Quran goes ahead and says
in Surah fan chapter number 25 verse
number 53 it is he who has let free two
bodies of flowing water one sweet and
palatable the other it is salty and
bitter though they meet they do not mix
there is a barrier which is forbidden to
be trespassed and today we know that
this Barak what the Quran speaks about
today those people who expert in the
subject of ocean ology they say this is
called as the Unseen
barrier the Quran it speaks about
biology inia 21 verse number
30 they have created every living thing
from water who could have believed in
the deserts of Arabia 1400 years ago
where there scarcity of water that every
living creature is made of water but
today science has testified that in the
field of
botony the Quran say says in Surah T
20:53 that we have created the plants in
pairs male and female previously we did
not know that even the plants are
created male and female Quran says in
Sur chapter number 13 verse number three
that we have created every kind of
fruits and
peirs in the field of
zoology the Quran says in Surah Anam
chapter number 6 verse number 38 that
the birds and the animals live in
community like the human beings which we
came to know recently Quran speaks about
the lifestyle of inah 16: 68 69 the
Quran speaks about the lifestyle of the
spider in Surah anab number 29: number
41 the Quran speaks about the lifestyle
of the ants in Surah namal chapter
number 27 verse number 17 18 all of
which we have come to know recently 50
years back 100 years back 200 years
back in the field of
medicine the Quran says in Surah Nel
chapter number 16 verse number 68 and 69
that we give to the human beings a drink
of verying
coming from the belly of the bee in
which there is healing for mankind today
we have come to know recently that the
honey is derived from the belly of the
bee and in the honey it has got
antiseptic properties no wonder the
Russians used honey to cover up the
wounds this we came to know recently in
the field of physiology the Quran speaks
about the blood circulation and the
production of milk and a nutshell in
Surah Nel 16: 66 in the of genetics the
Quran says in Surah naam chapter number
53 verse number
4546 as well as Sur 75 verse number 3739
that it is the male fluid the sperm
which is responsible for the sex of the
child which we have come to recently the
Quran speaks about embryology in great
detail in Sur alak 96 verse number one
that we have created the human beings
from alaka that's a leash like substance
something which clings it's also called
as a k clot of
blood the Quran speaks about the various
embryological stages in great detail
which modern embryology has just
discovered recently in
Sur 23 verse number 12 to
14 I'll just mention a couple
more normally the unbelievers the object
that how can almighty God once we have
died and we have been buried in the
ground in the dust how will almighty God
be be able to reassemble our bones after
our bones have got disintegrated on the
day of judgment how we be able to
reassemble the bones and almighty God
says in Surah chapter number 75 verse
number 3 and 4 that he can not only
reassemble the bones he can even
reassemble the very tips of the finger
in perfect
order and it was in 1880 that s Francis
gold discovered the fingerprinting
method and said that no two fingerprint
even in a millions of human beings even
in millions of human beings together no
two fingerprints
idal what the CIA the police the C the
FBI today they use the fingerprinting
method to identify the criminal Allah
mentions 1400 years ago he can not only
reassemble your bones he can even
reconstruct in perfect all the very tips
of your
finger when we ask the atheist that who
who could have mentioned this in the
Quran the only reply he can give you is
the creator it is a manufacturer it is
the inventor it is a maker it is a
producer this Creator this manufacturer
this inventor this maker this producer
we Muslims we call him as
Allah I have tried to summarize my two
hours lecture of is the Quran God's word
in only approximately 15 minutes so that
we can have more time for question
session just for the benefit of the
multiple times number of people that are
here according to Albert Einstein he
said
that science without religion is lame
and religion without science is
blind let me remind you the Glorious
Quran is not a book of signs s c i e n c
e but it's a book of signs s i g NS it's
a book of
ayats and in the Glorious Quran there
are more than 6,000 signs more than
6,000 ayats out of which more than a
thousand speak about
sence I'm not trying to take the help of
science to prove the authenticity of the
Quran for us
Muslims the Quran is a ytic but for the
non-muslims for the atheist for him
science is the yasti so I'm taking his
yasti and comparing with our yasik and
trying to prove that what your ytic has
mentioned yesterday 50 years back 100
years back 200 years back our yashik the
Glorious Quran has already mentioned 14
years
ago
that's the reason today's science is not
eliminating God but it is eliminating
models of God
ill so this glorious Quran has the
solution to the problems of humankind
and its author is the creator the
sustainer the cherisher of the whole
humankind of the whole
universe
there were several Revelations sent by
almighty God on the face of the Earth
but all the revelations that came before
the last and final Revelation glorious
Quran Were Meant only for a particular
group of people and it was meant to be
followed only for a particular time
period but since the Quran was the last
and final
revelation of almighty God Allah subhana
wa ta'ala it was not sent only for the
Muslims or the Arabs it was sent for the
whole of humankind it's mentioned in the
Quran in Bak chapter number 2 verse
number 185 that Ramadan was the month in
which the Quran was revealed as a
criteria for judgment from right and
wrong and as a guidance for the whole of
humankind not only for the Muslims or
for the Arabs for the whole of humankind
the same message is
repeated in Surah ibraim chapter number
14 verse number one in Surah ibraim
chapter number 14:52 as well as Surah
AUM 39:41 that the Quran has been sent
for the whole of
humankind similarly all the
messengers that came before the last and
final messenger Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon
him they were only sent for a particular
group of people and the message which
they brought was meant to be followed
only till a particular time period but
since Prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him
is the last and final messenger he was
not sent only for the Muslims or for the
Arabs the Quran says in Surah chapter
number 21 verse number
107 that we have sent thee not but as a
mercy to the whole of humanity as a
mercy to all the creatures as a mercy to
all the
worlds the same message is repeated inah
saah chapter number 34 Verse number
28 bash we have sent thee not but as a
universal messenger giving Glad Tidings
and warning them against sin but most of
the human beings yet do not
know and because most of the human
beings yet do not know that's the reason
we having such conferences and such
lectures but
today if we read if we hear if we notice
the international media there is
virulent
propaganda about Islam in the
international
media whether it be the international
news papers the international magazines
the radio broadcast stations the
international TV channels the
International satellite channels we find
in the international media they are
spreading many misconceptions about
Islam there is virent propaganda about
Islam and according to an article which
came in the Newsweek
magazine on 16th of April
1979 it say say that in a span of 150
years from 1800 to 1950 more than 60,000
books have been written against
Islam and if you calculate if you
divide the number of days and number of
books written more than one book was
written against Islam every
day and after
911 that 11th of September 2001
this has reached epidemic level every
day several books are written against
Islam if you want to get
famous if you write a book against Islam
the chances it will become a bestseller
is high and we notice that the
international media they use several
strategies to spread these misconception
about Islam number one is they pick up
the black sheep of the community
and they portray as though they're
exemplary
Muslims they black sheep in every
community so what the media does they
pick up the black sheep amongst the
Muslims they are not actually practicing
Muslims they namesake Muslims they pick
them up and they portray as though they
are exemplary
Muslims if you want to
know how good is the
and if you put behind the steering
wheel a person who does not know how to
drive the car and if he has an
accident if he bangs the car who will
you blame will you blame the car or the
driver who will you blame the car or the
driver but naturally the driver if you
want to know how good the car is you
have to analyze the
specification what is the fuel
consumption of the car what is the speed
what is the gear ratio what are the
safety
measures after analyzing these then can
you judge how good the car is and if you
want to really test drive the car put
behind the steering wheel a person who
is an expert driver and if you want to
judge Islam how good Islam is and you
really want to analyze an Exemplar
Muslim the best example it is a beloved
Prophet Muhammad sallallah Ali
[Applause]
wasallam look at his
s analyze the history of the prophet and
undoubtedly you'll have to
agree that this religion and the
follower of this religion mhammad
sallallah Ali wasallam he was the major
benefactor for the spreading of
Peace second strategy used is many times
they give quotations of the Quran and
the religious scriptures of Islam out of
context and we find that many
critics if you read many of the books
against Islam if you go on the internet
many sites against Islam and they give
references from the Quran as well as the
quotation and one quotation which is
very often used by the critics is of
Surah chapter number 9 verse number five
and this was also used by Arun Shi one
of the staunchest critics of Islam in
this country India his name is Arun
shuri and he writes in his
book The World of
fatwa and he gives the reference that
Quran says in Surah TBA chter 9 verse
number
five and it tells the Muslims that
wherever you find the
cfir into brackets is indicating
Hindus he's saying that the Quran says
in Surah TBA chapter 9 verse number five
that wherever you find the cfir
you have to kill
them and if you read the Quran if you
open the Quran and if you read the
translation what he's saying is correct
Surah Toba chapter number 9 verse number
5 does say that wherever you find the
kaf you kill them but it is quoted out
of
context for context you have to start
from verse number one of Surah TAA
chapter
9 and when you read the context and know
the
background why was this verse revealed
we come to know that there was a peace
treaty between the
Muslims and the mushrik of
Makkah and this peace treaty was
unilaterally broken by the mush of
Makkah so when this peace treaty was
unilaterally broken by the mushrik of
Makkah almighty God Allah subhana in the
Quran he says in Surah chapter 9 verse
number two that he's giving four months
time
otherwise there is a declaration of
war as mentioned s chter 9 verse number
five that after the four forbidden
months it is the Muslims that you
fight and you kill the
pagans that means your
enemies wherever you find them and seiz
them and for them in every strateg of
War so in context we come to know this
verse was revealed in the
battlefield that in the
battlefield when the peace treat is
broken and when the enemies come to
fight you don't get scared fight back
and kill them where you find them but
natural any army General in the
battlefield to boost up the moral of the
soldier he will still fight them
suppose there's a war going on between
us and
Vietnam and if the Army
general of
USA if he says that wherever you find
the vietnames you kill them but
naturally it's in context but if I quote
out of context and say that today the
Army general of America says that
wherever you find a Vietnam is today you
kill them I will make him sound like a
butcher but naturally to boost up the
morale almighty God will not say that
okay run away to boost up the morale he
has to say that don't get scared fight
and it's a fight between truth and
falsehood and such examples you'll find
in the Bible if you see in the gospel of
Matthew you'll find in the Hindu
scriptures in bhagwad Gita full bhagwat
Gita speaks about
that that Lord Krishan he is giving
advice to
Arjun Arjun in the
battlefield he says in bhagad Gita
chapter number one verse number 46 47 48
in the battlefield he puts his weapons
and says I would prefer being killed
unarmed than to fight my
relatives the SRI Krishna says just a
few ver later in bhagad Gita chapter
number 2 verse number 2 and three that
oh Arjun how can you be so
important it is the duty of the chhatria
it's the duty of the warrior to fight
and only if you fight will you go to the
Heavenly planet to the paradise and it
goes on and on you can see my cassette
on terrorism and Jihad where I spoken in
detail but when the Quran speaks about
this non-muslims have a problem imagine
if I say that bhagat Gita is saying kill
your relatives it will be delish and
bhag does say that if I say bhagat Gita
says kill your relatives it will be
devilish
in context it says that when you have to
fight against
unu if you have to fight against
operation stand for truth even if it be
against your
relatives and as far as this message of
bhad is concerned we are for
it Quran says the same therefore to make
the non-muslims understand
Islam according to me the master key
given in the Quran by our great Allah
subh
IM 3: 64 which
says come to come in terms as between us
and you the best way to make the
non-muslim understand Islam and Quran
is come to come in terms as between us
and you which is the first
term that we worship none but one
almighty God Allah subhana tala
and Arun shuri after quoting verse
number five of Surah Toba he jumps to
verse number
seven you know why verse number six has
the answer to his
sickness verse number six of Surah TBA
chapter number n says that if any of the
pagans if any of the disbelievers if any
of your enemies seek Asylum if they want
peace granted to them so that they may
hear the word of almighty God and escort
them to a place of security because
these are
men who do not understand the Quran does
not say just let them go today if the
enemy wants peace maximum the Army
General will say okay let him go Quran
does not say that Quran says escort them
to a place of
security because these are men who do
not
understand just a few months
back when I was giving a similar example
there's a non-muslim from audience who
said brother Zakir even you are quoting
out of context you haven't quoted the
full verse of Surah tah chapter 9 verse
number five that the full verse reads
after saying
that in the battlefield whever you find
the kafir kill them and slay them wait
for them in every stud strategy number
four it continues and says but if they
repent and if they establish prayers
regular prayers and regular
charity then let them go for Allah is
forgiving and
merciful so he's telling we come to know
that only if they accept Islam do you
have to leave
them see many of times it becomes
difficult for us to give the full
explanation other the lecture will be
maybe 10 hours long
as it is people say that I'm a marathon
speaker but I thank that Hindu brother
and said jaak for giving me an
opportunity for clarifying
more verse number five of Surah Toba
does refer that if the
unbeliever if he repents and establish
his regular prayer and gives regular
charity indicating he becomes a Muslim
then let him
go if he becomes the Muslim let him go
but verse number six says that if the
unbeliever seeks Asylum wants
peace don't just let him go escort him
to a place of security if he becomes a
Muslim let him go but if he does not
become a Muslim and wants
peace don't just leave him escort him to
a place of security because maybe now
he's in between he's on in the
fence those who accept Islam find
they're Muslims he wants peace maybe the
non-muslims they may kill him maybe the
non-muslim would like to take revenge
why is he wanting for Peace So almighty
God says in the Quran don't leave them
escort them to a place of
security so that the reason critics like
Arun shui they skip verses they quote
out of context and you can give hundreds
of such examples if you go on the
Internet it's very common and we find
now many of the non-muslims they go on
the internet and do speak against the
Quran has become easy therefore more
books are being published very easy you
know internet is a boon and a bane
initially when it started there were
more websites against Islam than for
Islam now Muslims have caught up there
are good sites
also but you don't have to be a
scholar to find alleged mistakes in the
Quran and it's difficult to reply the
moment you keep on replying more and
more keep on coming that the reason we
have open question answer
sessions so strategy number two is they
quote the verses of the Quran and the
Islamic scriptures out of
context third strategy
is